u.s president joe biden says russia will
soon
pay a price biden's strong words follow
a u.s intelligence report on foreign
interference in last november's
elections the report says
russian president vladimir putin
approved a campaign of misinformation
aimed at sowing discord
among the voters moscow has denied any
involvement
just as it has also denied meddling in
the 2016 vote
which saw a victory for donald trump
emily sherwin is in moscow oliver salad
on the other side of the atlantic in
washington to both of you good evening
emily let me start with you biden says
he considers putin to be a killer
strong words there any reaction from the
kremlin
well brent uh as you might imagine that
hasn't gone
down too well here in moscow the russian
foreign ministry has now
recalled uh the uh ambassador to the u.s
the russian ambassador to the u.s
for consultations about the future of
the u.s
russian relations and we saw a rather
sober statement from the
the spokesperson of the foreign ministry
who usually
has a bent towards kind of dramatic
statements
she said that the reason why
u.s relations are in such a bad way
is that the u.s has backed them into a
dead
end and she also warned about the fact
that
worsening relations um could be a risk
perhaps a hint at the fact that both
countries
are nuclear power so kind of a sober but
also a bit of a threatening statement
there
you have to imagine that this is a
personal
insult against uh putin in a country
where putin is kind of vladimir putin is
kind of considered
um untouchable on the political
landscape even his critics usually
just uh level accusations at the kremlin
or at the government but not at putin
himself
well emily when joe biden says that
putin
is a killer what exactly is the u.s
president
referring to
well during vladimir putin's time in
power there has
been a fairly long list of
deaths or assassination attempts of
kremlin critics that
of course his critics blamed on vladimir
putin himself or at least on the system
that he created
just a few examples are for example the
murder of um
opposition journalist anna politkovska
in 2006
the murder of opposition politician
baris niem sof in 2015 and the
failed assassination attempts of russian
spy sergey skripal in the uk and
last year of opposition politician
alexey navalny now those are all
attempted murders or murders that were
blamed squarely on the kremlin the
kremlin has always denied that and
investigations have
always have never found a direct link of
course to vladimir putin himself but
biden could be talking about those
oliver to you in washington did this
intelligence report just published it
blames moscow for meddling in u.s
elections to what extent did russia
try to sway the vote
well certainly not a very flattering
report brendan alleges that vladimir
putin the russian president directed
efforts
to help donald trump win the 2020
election in particular the report
tackles
covert operations to influence people
that were close to donald trump
so some analysts believe that one of the
persons targeted there
could have been rudy giuliani donald
trump's personal lawyer
at the time he was not mentioned but if
you remember giuliani
during the election campaign pushed
those baseless claims
of corruption about joe biden and his
son hunter biden
involving the ukraine and that narrative
also was pushed by russian intelligence
and if that sounds familiar to you then
yes of course it does because
uh just as a reminder the same happened
or similar happened
in 2016 special counsel robert mueller
then concluded that
putin was behind a very similar effort
so very much looks like history
repeating itself yeah a lot of repeating
going on here emily
we expected the kremlin to reject
accusations of election interference
this time just like it did
after the 2016 election but has there
been more of a reaction though
they've repeated their rejections of
election meddling
both for 2016 and 2020.
uh the kremlin spokesperson called this
new report
wrong baseless and unsubstantiated
uh today and kind of
pointed again to the fact that the west
is constantly
hitting russia with sanctions there's
very much
narrative here that that is part of a
russophobic
campaign on the part of the west and
oliver president biden he's threatening
russia with consequences i mean how
serious can
these consequences be considering that
he also says he wants to continue
working with russia where necessary i
think he said you know we can walk and
chew gum
at the same time
yeah well certainly typical biden
approach number one of course he stands
for the return of diplomacy that's
something that he has reiterated many
times since he took office at the same
time he promised
a tougher stance on russia in part
because of course he wants to distance
himself from donald trump who benefited
a lot from russian support
throughout his presidency and now you
see
the first steps if you will offer
tougher stance us just expanded
export risk restrictions on russia that
are from last month
as a result of the poisoning of
opposition leader alex navalny there
reportedly the u.s is just preparing
some new sanctions that could be put in
place as soon as next week
so a very different stance a very
different russia policy
under joe biden donald trump refused to
talk negatively about russia in public
and now you have biden calling putin a
killer
so of course he is it looks at least
like he is very serious
yeah very it sounds that way emily we
know that this white house is
certainly not the trump white house it's
not the
uh obama white house there's no reset
being
um sought after here by president biden
is moscow hunkering down for tough times
to come
well i think uh actually uh moscow
kind of had dashed hopes when it comes
to the donald trump administration
surprisingly enough
they expected more from trump and as a
result they didn't have high hopes at
all for the biden
administration and in a way today's
statement kind of
um confirms that but i did i do think
that they did hope that uh
the u.s and russia could have a kind of
bare bones
working relationship on certain issues
for example on
arms control on the iran nuclear deal
which
both uh want to work on um and i think
this statement today kind of uh does
come as somewhat of a blow in that sense
this personal insult certainly isn't a
good start uh for those relations which
are already at a
a pretty low point yeah yeah i think
there will be more reasons for us three
to get together and talk again in the
future emily sherwin in moscow oliver
salad in washington
to both of you thank you